here's what i'd say about uh matthew is
man he's a stud all right he's a stud he
is one of the toughest quarterbacks
you'll
you'll ever see um he's extremely
talented
um i know he's a team guy um
and and listen i know he wants to win
and
and so i'll leave it at that that's what
i do now
dan campbell looking extremely
comfortable in that suit
talking about biting off kneecaps
apparently matthew stafford has no
interest in biting off kneecaps of
opponents he wants out and the lions are
going to accommodate that request chris
where do you think he could go well uh
gosh there are so many options i mean
first off i mean it's extremely talented
i do think it's time to move on for
detroit for his purposes i mean but when
you go through the list
i mean wow we've hit on teams that have
quarterback needs you know hey the 49ers
i think they're a team right off the bat
should be thinking about it you know you
talk about the carolina panthers how
could they not get involved in that type
of conversation the new england patriots
boom the denver broncos maybe you think
about it drew locke hasn't necessarily
solidified things there i don't know
three-way trade desean watson all that
stuff could he end up in houston there's
too many possibilities he's too talented
everybody that needs a quarterback is
going to do their due diligence on matt
stafford
i love the idea of him playing for the
houston texans texas native when yeah
not he was born in tampa i was doing the
research last week born in tampa grew up
in dallas i went to texas went to high
school same high school bobby lane
attended in texas and then went to the
university of georgia so he's got
different connections hey the falcons
could be a connection sure matt ryan
knows but uh look the guy's still only
32
only 32 years old but the time has come
for him to move on he depending upon
what he's done by way of taking care of
himself he could play another 10 years
we've seen quarterbacks play into their
40s the rules are conducive to it yeah
he's played through plenty of injuries
yeah but uh now he gets a chance to go
somewhere and chris where he needs to go
is a team with
a great built-in leadership structure
because that's the thing he's always
shied away from right is the active in
your face there's a new sheriff in town
leadership you need he's like eli
manning in that regard you know
it's the scale of peyton manning to eli
manning ultra involved sheriff in your
face and eli just kind of i just work
here which is fine he won two super
bowls right
but you need guys
michael strahan justin thompson the jpps
in the locker room to go hey guys let's
get the hell going today here we go with
that you're exactly right yeah that's
not that's not him he's going to do his
job he's going to do everything he's got
to do but yeah it doesn't seem like he's
uh rally the troops everybody i'm going
to lead us here's a speech whatever it
may be but the the thing that's
interesting to me more than anything
mike is what you brought up is the age
it's just different than you know it's a
franchise quarterback here
who's got a lot of good years left it's
not like whoa we see you know the light
at the end of the tunnel and this is
over sometime soon no this is a guy
where you can go wait his arm the way he
throws the football he's gonna have a
top arm and he's 44 years old it's it's
that type of arm and use you know he's
tough plays through injury never been
protected never really had a run game
and at all in his career to the last two
years i mean i'm with you i'd love to
see him go somewhere where you're right
there's a culture
you know there's an offensive coach that
really knows how to use them you know
it's another place where yeah i look at
my buddy kyle shanahan and i would love
to see that match up with stafford and
that offense and those things i would
love that
reggie bush spent some time with the
lions i was doing some research over the
weekend about things he had said in the
past
one of the complaints he had when he
left the lions was there's no chemistry
there and when you think about how they
accumulate talent i don't know how much
thought past regimes have put into
how your personalities will interact and
where the leaders will come from you
need to have that though you have to
have guys who are deliberately selected
for their leadership potential then they
grow into the leaders they blossom into
the people who hold players accountable
right and do the things that make a team
better than the individual parts would
suggest that's what the lions need and
stafford needs to go somewhere where
those parts are in place
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports